muy buena pregunta
en efecto vemos un efecto generacional
biden tiene edad avanzada ochenta años
sin embargo también recordemos que Trump
tiene 76 no es mucho más joven y gente
donde generaciones más jóvenes como por
ejemplo Obama ya fueron presidentes y
las nuevas generaciones políticas de
izquierda como Ocasio Cortés son aún muy
jóvenes entonces parece que hay un un
trecho muy grande entre la gente de
avanzada edad carrera política como
biden y gente más joven hay que recordar
dos cosas rápidamente una es que biden
es el presidente electo y muy rara vez
un presidente electo no decide correr a
la reelección Por lo cual el continuará
tiene buena salud y la otra es que él es
una persona que estuvo mucho tiempo en
el senado donde hay bastantes personas
de edad avanzada que siguen siendo
senadores y muchos de ellos bastante
eficientes bueno en principio biden será
candidato y es bastante probable que
Donald Trump sea el candidato
republicano en 2024 lo que llevaría a
revivir el duelo de 2020 pero que ha
cambiado en estos años en el discurso de
ambos y Qué probabilidades tiene biden a
día de hoy de revalidar El mandato
ya ya el ganó las elecciones a Trump la
vez pasada Entonces es muy probable que
que lo volviera a hacer Trump cada vez
tiene menos seguidores enfrenta más
casos políticos y criminales Por lo cual
vendría aún más debilitado eh Trump es
una persona que levanta pasiones eh
bastante fuertes a favor por su base y
en contra mucha gente que que no tiene
una opinión favorable sobre él en
contraste va es una persona que no
levanta muchas pasiones ni a favor no
tiene tantos fanáticos como tiene Trump
pero tampoco tiene tantos enemigos o
gente que lo que de verdad lo odie hay
algunas frases y algunas temas que sean
pero que se han usado mucho en Fox news
y otros medios de derecha sin embargo ya
todos los ataques que se pueden hacer
contra biden se han hecho y él los eh
los está enfrentando bien en cambio este
tramos una persona bastante bastante
desgastada Por lo cual la reelección de
de todo marcha igual no pinta tan
descabellada vamos a lo discursivo
porque en su anuncio biden ha usado un
mensaje claro libertad los republicanos
acusan Sin embargo a los demócratas de
ser unos radicales de izquierda que
buscan cercenar libertades Más allá de
estas soflamas que proyectos están
proponiendo los partidos y Qué
consecuencias pueden tener para el
futuro del país
Sí es muy interesante que en este video
vayan usa el el argumento de que votar
por él serían más derechos más más
libertad la libertad de ese tema de la
libertad es algo que ha usado mucho la
la derecha los republicanos en Estados
Unidos sin embargo en este caso se
refiere al derecho al aborto que era un
derecho que tenía la Constitución
americana o la ley americana que se ha
sido quitado y un poquito la libertad
por ejemplo en el sentido de tener
acceso a salud pública a empleo cosas
así que ha hecho bastantes leyes y
algunas de ellas bipartidistas en
Estados Unidos para mejorar por ejemplo
la infraestructura
temas ambientales invertir en más
empresas e industria americana y que
está tratando de vender biden como otra
manera de ver la libertad que sea
diferente a la que por ejemplo tenía el
partido el tip party que era alguien que
atacaba a a barracobama cuando era
presidente y va de no tenido ese ese
tipo de movimientos social en su contra
que vimos por ejemplo incluso con con
Obama o con